j'ai toujours beaucoup de bordel quand
je voyage vers les smartphones cost est
sûre on pique ma valise
je suis mort qu est ce parce qu'on va
parler bientôt j'espère y avoir droit
parle bientôt ça c'est une mode connecté
de son fils qui justement on reparle
bientôt
et puis le black shark 2 qui est là on
va parle aussi bientôt mais aujourd'hui
on n'est pas là pour parler de ça
aujourd'hui je vous emmène alors on est
à 1 ici là dans cet hôtel la norme innus
qui est un hôtel en plein centre d'arles
pour parler du festival en jeu pas si
vous savez mais tous les autres vous
avez festival de la photo tu énormes
festivals et depuis quatre ans il ya le
festival de la réalité virtuelle qui est
présent à de si l'on reste sur dans
l'image ça c'est vachement cool
[Musique]
donc vous joins calme sur la chaîne de
monsieur creux comme pouvoir je suis à
100 smart phone il ne sait pas encore
tout simplement parce que monsieur est
en train de s'amuser tous dans une
chaise roulante
j'espère que vous m'entendez je crois
qu'il n'entend pas encore tu fais pas
très attention mais ça c'est drôle hein
regardez donc la grande question cet
homme s'il va utiliser cette vidéo ou
pas dans sa prochaine vidéo
donc si il utilise sa vidéo je me fais
un peu de pub
anne fans et ses cafés
[Musique]
oh
et ce festival de la réalité virtuelle
permet de découvrir des univers jusque
là inconnu on se met ce petit truc sur
la tête pour l'hygiène alors je sais
c'est très beau mais c'est vachement
bien pour l'hygiène et ensuite vous
venez mettre votre caste de verre vous
rentrez vraiment en immersion
alors l'idée c'est que vous avez
plusieurs films qui sont représentés qui
sont l'envers et qui vont donner des
expériences différentes revisitant de
politique de ce qu'on peut avoir au
niveau du film alors on n'est pas du
tout dans le sensationnalisme qu'on
n'est pas dans ce qu'on peut retrouver
sur des jeux notamment aux sables et les
trains de la mine roller coaster les
films d'horreur tous ces trucs là qui
sont vraiment sensationnel et qui au
bout d'un moment vous donne un peu la
gerbe
lorsque vous jouez à des jauges pas si
vous l'avez fait je sais pas si vous
utilisez delà de la réalité virtuelle
d'ailleurs dites le moi en bas en
commentaire mais moi j'adore la vr pour
ça génial d'y jouer mais il ya certains
jeux qui au bout d'un moment ça me file
des nausées et japonais alors ça dépend
des gens que ça passe très bien et je te
récompense j'adore ça mais là on n'est
pas dans côté divertissement en terme de
jeu on est dans le côté un peu plus
contemplatif mais on prend part aux
trucs toria plusieurs expériences et
tout qu'est vraiment dingue benoît ça va
super bon tu es le directeur du festival
c'est ça oui tu peux me parler de la
jeunesse de l'historique du festival le
festival on la crée en 2016 avec cette
idée qui était de dire que
en 2016 tout ce qu'on voyait en verre
c'était plutôt fait par des techniciens
ouais beaucoup plus sur la science
fiction on avait beaucoup de choses qui
étaient de l'ordre très
et très technique des roller coaster des
choses comme ça que tu es des prouesses
et en termes de technologie sur du jeu
vidéo tu veux dire soit du jeu vidéo ou
même ce qu'on voyait en dehors du jeu
vidéo c'est la prouesse l'accord mais
y'avait pas forcément d'écriture est pas
forcément une notion est l'auteur de
narration
d'univers un peu artistique et dans ce
festival on a voulu mettre en avant des
nouvelles écritures liés à la vrs que ça
pouvait permettre en termes onirique
affaires de narration et en termes de
performances simple
[Musique]
ça c'est le dépliant du festival dans
lequel vous allez retrouver tous les
films du festival d'auvers ils sont
représentés et vous avez j'ai pas tout
fait et j'en ai fait plusieurs hier j'ai
attendu aujourd'hui pour par vous en
parler pour pouvoir être un peu dormir
dessus ou faire une idée déjà
l'expérience
alors ça dépend des films et
l'expérience est vachement bien alors on
savait assez de la brc immersif
il ya plusieurs types d'expériences
d'une expérience d'un marchand remarquer
c'est ça s'appelle psychose hills alors
le truc en fait comme sont indécis
qu'osisko saintrick est complètement fou
en fait je vous fais le pitch vous
arrivez vous êtes dans une espèce de
deux salles qui rookie reconstitue en
hôpital psychiatrique
vous avez un fauteuil roulant sur lequel
vous êtes bien évidemment de la terre
vous avez une p'tite [ __ ] pour avancer
pendant virtuel dans lequel vous êtes et
puis peut tourner votre fauteuil parce
qu'il est sur un espèce de pivot à 360
vous dépasser dans votre fauteuil pour
faire tourner et vous déplacer dans ce
monde comme ça en réalité avec des
vraies sensations tout est complètement
fou ça se base sur le texte de la
dramaturge britannique sarah kane qui a
rédigé dans une clinique psychiatrique
au début de 1999 peu de temps avant son
suicide vient toquer quand même
vachement lourd le spectateur se
retrouve à l'intérieur des visions
surréalistes de l'héroïne de l'oeuvre de
sarah kane et s'engagent dans un voyage
cité délit qui commence dans un vrai
couloir d'hôpital et ceux proches dans
un espace virtuel
en gros vous êtes dans un hôpital vous
avez passez une porte et là ça devient
complètement fou truc en sachet je veux
pas vous spoiler le truc mais c'est
vraiment un truc sur est et ce qui est
génial c'est là justement le côté
immersif et surtout le côté vous avez
des objets ou c'est vous qui vous
déplacez vous êtes vraiment dans vous
baissez les gens vous voyez vos jambes à
un photographe a le truc est vraiment
ouf
lorsque tu entres en fait à ce point
sur une plage une cloche dresser une
plage avec un lac aimons ce lac vagues
et des mains j'avais moins bons
résultats sur en fait chaque fois tu
cliques sur ce bouton tu cries non
d'accord et le pied en fait tu peux tu
réellement besoin grande en conscient du
temps d'appui et du prg imaginent que tu
crées une main qu'il a des mains qui
sort dans toutes les espèces de mme
aubry comme aux brocolis
ouais c'est dégueulasse je suis pas je
suis partie stick en fait compte la
journée il est clair à ben justement ça
ça me cause des super 7 je me suis un
peu énervé
j'écris beaucoup de mains je suis un peu
énervé il a du coup d éclat rappeurs
comme ça que ça va marcher je peux
écouter hyper venus en bus à bayaa
évacuant super saiyan en tout cas le cas
ce que tout va très bien j'ai bien
d'autres que j'appelle ayahuasca
wasquehal possible connaissez c'est une
drogue qu'on fait en groupe e qui vous
fait faire des voyages hallucinant et on
est justement dans une pratique
spirituelle et donc justement là on
rentre dans un voyage du coton consomme
de l'ayahuasca et qui plane complètement
donc vous êtes en espèces de sic et
délicat avec des chants tchaman enfin
tout est complètement ouf on reste dans
l'inertie fsss et vous est posée par
tags des espèces de petites bougies
enfin ça vous transporte vraiment
ailleurs et c'est cool parce que c'est
vraiment ça qui pousse l'expérience je
dirais du voyage du film encore plus
loin en rien un truc que j'ai adoré
c'est ça la s'appelle guillaume hirise
la création est dingue parce que vous
êtes là et donc c'est tout loire vous
êtes debout pouvez vous déplacer et vous
voyez une espèce de seine qui est devant
vous qui s'ouvre avec un espèce de
méchants et vous avez espace de bono et
des dizaines d'yeux green eyes et puis
vu une histoire est en fait vous êtes
passionné là il ya la scène de vente on
peut vous pouvez vous rapprochez vous
vous rapprochez vous regardez de plus
près vous pouvez vous promener un peu
autour vous êtes vraiment dans la salle
ça doit s'appliquer génial et hop ça
c'est un homme comme au théâtre
sa baisse la lumière et le bonhomme se
déplace il va sur une autre scène et
s'est pas fait ça fait tout le tour de
vous donc le truc c'est vous tournez
vous balader autour de l'oeuvre vous
regardez vous êtes curieux comme ça
c'est assez impressionnant et à la fin
ça finit le plan est assez haut vous
hanter tout petit par rapport à ça vous
peut vous rapporter ne pouvez pas vous
montre pas d'escale rouille et ça ça
donne des
respectifs complètement différente et
c'est ça que je trouve vraiment génial
je crois que le cinéma envers plusieurs
années ça pourrait remplacer le cinéma
ou en tout cas prendre une part aussi
importante que le cinéma que de la même
manière qu'eux ne m'a pas tué la photo
que la télé a pas tué le cinéma je reste
pareil que la paire maître du cinéma
d'accord mais par contre elle va
cohabiter à côté à la porte à une autre
forme et d'expérience et puis il ya
peut-être des gens qui n'iront plus au
cinéma qui sont là
dr des gens qui ne rend pas du tout amer
qui contiendra le cinéma qui est des
gens qui font les deux camps je pense
qu'après c'est une histoire d'offre
culturelle mais je pense que ça par
contre ça va prendre une part très
importante dans un monde immersif
globale et on va pas parler de vr un peu
par les airs à la fin on va parler de le
monde dit merci
vous avez un autre truc qui s'appelle la
seven days alors ça c'est vachement bien
mais c'est aussi hyper dur steven lane
c'est l'histoire d'une jeune femme qui
dans le métro de tokyo est bien va se
suicider donc vous arrivez vous êtes sur
le quai du métro à tokyo lors du métro
qui arrive
il ya des gens et puis vous voyez vous
pas ce que jean ferrat il arrive donc
scène d'horreur vous commencé c'était ça
vous prend alors sa fais pareil truc
vous voyez pas là ça n'a rien de trash a
pas de sens tout ça mais vous êtes
dedans et ensuite vous avez une espèce
de deux quais un peu floutée et vous
vous approchez vous choisissez la
personne à laquelle vous voulez vous
approcher pour venir rentrer dans son
histoire et comprendre des moments qui
ont été des moments clés du moment un
peu un peu un peu de drame à un peu
compliqué de sa vie donc le truc qui
ouvre là dedans s'il voulait c'est que
de quelle manière le spectateur va
pouvoir rentrer dans un monde
complètement en immersion va pouvoir
interagir avec différentes personnes
comprendre et c'est vraiment vous qui
fait le choix d'aller plus la dalle est
plus là ça fait penser quand j'étais
gamin vous savez pas si vous avez eu
c'est rien ça existe encore je croise et
les livres dont vous êtes le héros vous
lisiez et vous arrivez vous est une
histoire et ça vous emmener à telle page
alors c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose mais dans l'idée de la
construction c'est un peu ça c'est à
dire que vous êtes dans l'histoire c'est
vous qui faites le choix d'aller là
devoir s'adapter vraiment très
interactif les intrigue intéressante
alors offs et tu me disait ton cerveau
les responsables est un film en verre et
un film sur un écran classique c'est pas
la même chose c'est pas stocker de la
même manière en fait quand tu vis une
expérience en verrez
par le même endroit de ton cerveau que
quand tu vas voir un concert ou que tu
vas boire un coup avec des copains
ou que tu fais quelque chose de vécu
d'accord tandis que quand on voit un
film sur netflix ou qu'on écoute de
l'audio ça se met dans un autre endroit
du cerveau qui justement les choses qui
sont enregistrés qui sont pas devoir de
l'expérience cela que raconte la br bien
se mettre dans l'endroit du cerveau qui
est de l'ordre de tous qui expérience de
tout ce qui est vécu et voilà et c'est
ce qui montre qu'il ya une dimension
différente dans ce port technique il ya
quelque chose qui reste rapport qui en
nous et qui reste présent et c'est ça
qui je pense une voix extrêmement
intéressante à explorer dans la
rappelez moi le festival du coup il a
les deux camps alors on a commencé le
1er juillet et on va jusqu'au 25 août
ok c'est tous les jours il n'y a pas à
pas d'interruption du lundi au dimanche
de 10h à 19h30
et il ya notamment des films qui sont
fléchés pour les enfants donc on peut
commencer à cet ovaire
alors si sept ans j'étais d'ailleurs
tous les vendredis après midi à des
ateliers pour les enfants pour leur
permettre de découvrir la br ils vont
tourner leur propre opinion de ce qui
est génial et ce que je trouve vraiment
intéressante et estivale c'est que on
voit d'une que la vert est là avec le
cinéma permet des interactions ya un
champ des possibles on voit que les
personnes qui construisent ces films
scouts qui construisent ces scénarios
test différentes choses il ya plein de
choses différentes il ya un succès
accuse de numéro deux sur le procès de
nelson mandela en afrique du sud
vous aviez son numéro 2 qui s'appelle
walter sisulu
et ça vous monte son procès lors ya des
heures d'archivés oméga aucune archive
vidéo et du coup vous avez une semaine
d'animations où ils ont dessiné le
procès avec cet homme avec les avocats
donc bon vous sentez tout petit mais
costaud qui sont énormes qui gueulent
enfin ça vous plonge dedans c'est
immersif donc ça propose plein de films
je vous invite vraiment si vous passez
pas un venez voir le festival de réalité
virtuelle c'est la quatrième édition
c'est au couvent saint césaire c'est
c'est un petit truc ce vous arrivez vous
est dense dans un endroit public très
silencieux les gens parlent pas fort
vous inscrivez à des films et les gens
et vous appelez tenez vous venez là vous
avez dans votre salle dans une salle p
non poser vos affaires et tranquille
père sécurisé et vous êtes dans votre
expérience à truquer génial et ça montre
vraiment le là où on va aller je pense
au niveau du cinéma donc maintenant la
question c'est est-ce que la vr peut
remplacer le cinéma est ce que la
réalité virtuelle vous fera que dans
quelques années avec l'amélioration des
technologies parce qu'on encore cet
effet gris sur les sur les casques s'est
pas encore parfait mais ça évolue
quand on doit vraiment des casques avec
de meilleure qualité avec un angle de
vision encore plus large
ça permettra d'aller encore plus loin et
je pense que dans quelques bonnes années
la réalité virtuelle en expérience
propre mais mon expérience collective va
vraiment être en complément du cinéma je
ne suis pas sûr servait de remplacer le
cinéma ça doit venir en complément
est ce que j'ai vu en expérience l'a
bien croyez moi que ça redessine
vachement de choses par rapport à ce que
j'ai vu en verre l'averse et récréatif
aujourd'hui c'est du jeu là avec ses
différents types de créations ça pousse
à la réflexion sur ce que peut être le
cinéma sur ce qu'on peut faire et on
voit pour final on peut vraiment aller
en interaction et vous pourriez même
être imaginé un film dans lequel vous
vous êtes le héros donc ça joue ça
complètement dingue
donc j'ai encore pris 1
la caméra de monsieur groupe il est
encore en train de jouer non mais je
comprends pas comment on fait pour
bloguer avec un geste sympa ce que
ferait un blood brass et hyper low me
tuerait
très fun d'ailleurs je commençais à
faire une expérience bizarre
vraiment si vous n'êtes pas loin de voir
cet été en vacances si vous êtes à nîmes
dans le coin aux saintes maries
marseille ce que vous voulez venez faire
un tour
le truc est vraiment hyper bluffant et
ne serait ce que pour découvrir autre
chose découvrir une autre vision de la
vertu sans vraiment vraiment vraiment
génial qu'est ce que vous pensez vous
tout ça par rapport à la vr au cinéma
est-ce que vous pensez que la ver peut
remplacer le cinéma est ce que pense que
c'est un bon complément il faut imaginer
des techno plus avancées aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment le début on nous début de
l'écriture de l'histoire donc c'est
comme le début du cinéma
les auteurs cherchent thèse des choses
et tout ils sont bien d'autres qui sont
un peu moins bien du capot de blizzard
inc un peu fou mais tout y est là et le
truc annonce et tout ça vraiment génial
dites moi ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires
et moi je veux rendez vous demain des
bisous chaos
[Musique]